[Musique]
je suis agent au Sénat je suis
administratrice adjointe administratrice
jardinier au jardin du Luxembourg je
suis chef du service de sécurité du
sénatiste je suis assistante de
direction en commission
on travaille au plus près des
parlementaires j'siste directement les
présidents de séances la relation
politique elle est fondamentale dans
notre métier on travaille plusieurs fois
par semaine avec plusieurs sénateurs
différents la proximité avec le
politique je la trouve très intéressante
puisque finalement vous participez à
l'exécution du service public
parlementaire notre mission qui est de
faciliter les missions démocratiques des
élus et fonctionnaires servent à quelque
chose à faire fonctionner l'institution
c'est un métier complètement
indispensable au fonctionnement de la
démocratie représentative être au coeur
de la machine politique c'est absolument
passionnant
au coeur de l'hémicycle en dessous de la
tribune de l'orateur et du président de
la présidente de séance l'hémicycle
c'est un open space un peu particulier
on sent que on participe à la continuité
de l'action de l'État il y a énormément
de fonctions qui finalement ont
contribue à ce que les sénateurs
travaillent de manière sereine de
support logistique de montage d'audition
dans le cadre des rapports d'information
travailler au Sénat pour moi est
toujours été une source de fierté je
trouve qu'on fait un travail
d'excellence
j'apprécie tout particulièrement
également le fait de travailler dans une
institution à dimension humaine il
dimension collective qui est assez
agréable c'est un engagement profond on
travaille pour des gens qui s'engagent
du travail le Sénat est un lieu
passionnant et stimulant où on peut
travailler et s'épanouir
professionnellement
[Musique]
c'est un une institution qui a
provocation principale de voter la loi
de contrôler l'action du gouvernement et
nous avons également tout un patrimoine
à gérer dans un palais du 17e siècle ce
qui est vraiment une grande chance pour
nous c'est un endroit avec une histoire
très très riche mais également en
institution qui est très importante pour
la vie démocratique de notre pays pour
moi c'est un honneur de travail dans ce
jardin parce que c'est vraiment un lieu
magique dans le jardin donc on est en
contact avec eux en permanence et on
répond à leurs questions pour moi
c'était une continuité de servir la loi
et de servir ce qu'il a fait
[Musique]